WASHINGTON, I AM LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
ORGANIZED HATRED IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
REMEMBER IN 2009 WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS SPEAKING AT
NOTRE DAME AND HE SAID THIS
ABOUT THE NEED FOR CIVIL
DISCOURSE?
>> AS CITIZENS OF A VIBRANT AND
VERY DEMOCRACY, HOW DO WE ENGAGE
IN VIGOROUS DEBATE?
HOW DOES EACH OF US REMAIN FIRM
WITHOUT, AS FATHER JOHN SAID IT,
DEMONIZING THOSE WITH JUST AS
STRONGLY HELD CONVICTIONS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> Laura: WHAT A NICE
SENTIMENT.
BUT WHERE IS HE TONIGHT.
WHAT DOES HE SAY ABOUT THE
THREATS ABOUT AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION?
SOMEHOW THE DEMOCRATS WENT FROM
HOPE AND A CHANGE TO, NOPE, AND
DERANGED.
OVER THE WEEKEND TO COME UP THE
OWNER OF THE LEXINGTON VIRGINIA
EATERY, YOU PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT
IT, CALLED THE RED HEN DID
SOMETHING PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
SHE ASKED HOW SPOKESPERSON SARAH
SANDERS TO LEAVE THE RESTAURANT
SIMPLY BECAUSE SHE WORKED FOR
TRUMP.
THE OWNER OF THE RED HEN TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST," I HAVE A
BUSINESS AND I WANT THE BUSINESS
TO THRIVE.
THIS FEELS LIKE THE MOMENT IN
OUR DEMOCRACY WHERE PEOPLE HAVE
TO MAKE UNCOMFORTABLE ACTIONS
AND DECISIONS TO UPHOLD THEIR
MORALS.
SO, MISS MORALITY AND WALKED
SARAH HUCKABEE OUTSIDE AND TOLD
HER THAT THE RED HEN HAS
"CERTAIN STANDARDS THAT I FEEL I
HAVE TO HOLD."
AND SHE INVITED HUCKABEE TO
LEAVE WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY DID.
HUCKABEE RETURNED HOME WITH HER
HUSBAND FOR THE REST OF THE
FAMILY WENT TO ANOTHER
RESTAURANT ACROSS THE STREET.
THAT DIDN'T STOP WILKINSON OR
HER CRUSADE TO DRIVE
CONSERVATIVES.
APPARENTLY FROM ESTABLISHMENTS,
EVEN ONES SHE DOESN'T RUN, IN
WAS ON MY RADIO SHOW TODAY.
>> THAT'S PART OF THAT STORY
THAT HASN'T BEEN TOLD AND YOU
WILL BE THE FIRST TO HEAR IT.
SARAH AND HER HUSBAND JUST WENT
HOME, THEY HAD SORT OF HAD
ENOUGH.
BUT THE REST OF HER FAMILY WENT
ACROSS THE STREET TO A DIFFERENT
RESTAURANT.
THE OWNER OF THE RED HEN,
BECAUSE NOBODY HAS TOLD THIS,
THEN FOLLOWED THEM ACROSS THE
STREET, CALLED PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZE A PROTEST, YELLING AND
SCREAMING OUTSIDE FROM OUTSIDE
OF THE OTHER RESTAURANT.
>> Laura: PUBLICLY SHAMING
CONSERVATIVES INTO TARGETING
THEM IN PUBLIC.
THAT'S BECOME THE NEW TACTIC OF
THE LEFT.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO MALIGN THEM
FOR THEIR BELIEF AND POSITION,
NOW THEY HAVE TO BE PUBLICLY
HUMILIATED, INCLUDING THEIR
FAMILIES AND, YOU BET, THEY ARE
ARE LIBERALS AND DON'T EVEN LIKE
TRUMP.
HOLLYWOOD IS GETTING IN ON THE
ACTION, TOO.
ACTOR SETH ROGEN BRAGGED ON TV
HOW HE RECENTLY EMBARRASSED
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN FRONT OF HIS
CHILDREN.
>> AND HE SAID TO COME, I HAVE A
STANDING RIGHT THERE,
EXPECTANTLY, CLEARLY FANS OF
MINE, AND I SAID, NO WAY, MAN!
AND I COULDN'T STOP.
AND I SAID FURTHERMORE, I HATE
COUNT THE DAYS UNTIL YOU KNOW
LONGER HAVE ONE IOTA OF THE
POWER THAT YOU CURRENTLY HAVE.
AND I LOOK OVER AND HIS KIDS ARE
STILL STANDING RIGHT THERE.
>> Laura: NICE GUY.
I ALWAYS GET THEM MIXED UP WITH
JONAH HILL FOR SOME REASON.
BUT IF I WERE SETH ROGEN, I
WOULD BE TRYING TO KEEP
EVERYTHING AND I COULD.
BONDI ATTENDED A SHOWING OF
MR. ROGERS, A DOCUMENTARY WHICH
IRONICALLY IS ALL ABOUT CIVILITY
AND KINDNESS.
APPARENTLY THE LEFT-WING MOB WHO
CONFRONTED AND AFFLICTED SPIT ON
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF FLORIDA
ABOUT YOU?
TAKING AWAY HEALTH INSURANCE?
SHAME ON YOU!
>> Laura: SO THAT'S THE VIDEO
OF BONDI LEAVING THE THEATER, SO
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED.
BUT AS SHE CAME IN, SHE AND HER
BOYFRIEND WERE VERBALLY
ASSAULTED AND PHYSICALLY
THREATENED IN THE CONCESSIONS
EVERY CURSE WORD IN THE BOOK AND
THEY SAID TO HIM, HEY BLUE EYES,
AREN'T YOU GOING TO PROTECT HER?
AND USING LOTS OF OTHER WORDS,
TOO.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
THEY ARE THIS FAR FROM MY FACE,
ONE SPIT ON MY HEAD, THEY WERE
TRYING TO CREATE A FIGHT.
>> Laura: YOU THAT THEY WERE.
IF THIS CONTINUES, SOMEONE IS
GOING TO GET HURT.
IMAGINE A A FEW YEARS AGO, OBAMA
OFFICIALS WHO WERE HARASSED AND
VERBALLY ASSAULTED IN THAT WAY?
THERE WOULD BE CAUSE FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO STEP IN.
BUT SINCE CONSERVATIVES ARE
TARGETED, ALL BETS ARE OFF AND
ALL STANDARDS OUT THE WINDOW.
THIS IS ALL EVOLVING INTO A TYPE
OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM AND IT'S
ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
RESTAURANT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
LAST WEEK BY ANGRY PROTESTERS.
PROTESTERS ARE STAKED OUTSIDE OF
HIS APARTMENT BUILDING.
THEY EVEN STAGED A PROTEST
OUTSIDE OF NIELSEN'S HOME,
BLARING AUDIO OF THIS CHILD
SEPARATION AT A BORDER FACILITY.
THESE ARE ANARCHIC, ORGANIZED
EACH FLASH PROTEST IS PLANNED
OUT AND CHOREOGRAPHED.
ITS PLANNED ONLINE FIRST, AGAIN,
AND IT'S MEANT TO SHAME THE
POLITICAL OPPONENT TO STOKE
VIOLENCE AND HATRED.
AND MAYBE EVEN INTIMIDATE PEOPLE
IN THE FUTURE FROM GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AT ALL.
THEN AT A WEEKEND RALLY, THIS IS
THE BEST.
CONGRESSMAN MAXINE WATERS ISSUED
HER OWN VERY SOFT CALL TO ACTION
HER OWN VERY SOFT CALL TO ACTIO
ACTION.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE PUT
UP WITH THIS PRESIDENT LONG
ENOUGH.
WHAT MORE LIES DO WE NEED TO
HEAR?
DO YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, IN A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
GATHER A CROWD.
AND YOU PUSH BACK ON THEM.
>> Laura: WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
PHRASE, PUSH BACK ON THEM, AND
JUST A MOMENT.
WE INVITED MS. WATERS AND A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS TO APPEAR
TONIGHT, NO SURPRISE, THEY ALL
REFUSED.
SHE DID FIND TIME TO GO ON MSNBC
TONIGHT AND SUNDAY TO SHARE THIS
UNIFYING MESSAGE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STOP AT A GAS STATION.
IT WON'T BE ABLE TO SHOP AT A
DEPARTMENT STORE.
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TURN ON
THEM, THEY ARE GOING TO PROTEST.
THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY HARASS THEM
UNTIL THEY DECIDE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO TELL THE PRESIDENT,
APPROACH THEM, DRIVE THEM OUT,
PUSH THEM BACK.
SO IS MAXINE WATERS PUSHING
VIOLENCE USING HER POSITION?
PAUL RYAN STOOD AT THE VERY
THINK THEY SHOULD MOVE TO
CENSURE HER.
SHE SEEMS TO BE USING HER OFFICE
TO JUSTIFY ACTS OF HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, THAT COULD VERY
THE WHITE HOUSE TO SEE PELOSI
FORCED WATERS TO THE MICROPHONE
NONAPOLOGY DOUBLE-TALK 48 HOURS
AFTER HER INCENDIARY AND
OUTRAGEOUS STATEMENTS THAT SHE
REPEATED YESTERDAY ARE
SUFFICIENT TO CALL WHILE THE
FIRESTORM, SHE HAS ANOTHER THING
STATEMENT, ANYTIME, ANYPLACE,
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CIVILITY
BUT PROTEST IS STABILITY.
>> Laura: DRY THEM OUT, HARASS
ALL THINGS THAT PEOPLE TOOK AWAY
FROM WHAT SHE SAID IN HER VERY
WORDS.
SO THREATENING WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AT A DINNER, AT THE
MOVIES, IS CIVIL?
NO WONDER SHE'S TOO AFRAID TO
COME ON.
SHE WILL ONLY GO TO THE SOFTBALL
INTERVIEWS ON MSNBC.
MAYBE SHE SHOULD COME ON A SHOW
SHE CAN'T INTIMIDATE.
NOT APOLOGIZE FOR HER COMMENTS
IN THE LEAST.
THE WOMAN HAS BEEN SAYING CRAZY
HATEFUL IN INCENDIARY THINGS FOR
YEARS.
THE DIFFERENCE NOW IS THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS DRIFTED
INTO MAXINE LAND.
>> AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED, THE
TEA PARTY CAN GO STRAIGHT TO
HELL.
I DON'T HONOR HIM, I DON'T
RESPECT HIM AND I DON'T WANT TO
BE INVOLVED.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAD BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS IS A BUNCH OF SCUMBAGS.
LET'S IMPEACH 45!
IMPEACH 45!
>> Laura: THE LEFT WANTS TO
CRY TARGETING PEOPLE, AND
BECAUSE CONSERVATIVES ARE THE
SINCE THEY BELIEVED TRUMP'S
POLICIES ARE DETESTABLE, OR
SORRY,-LIKE, THEY BLAME TRUMP OF
COURSE.
>> SHOULD SOMEONE BE OPENLY
WELCOMED IN SOCIETY WHEREVER
THEY PLEASE?
I WOULD SAY THE POLITE DISCOURSE
IS INAPPROPRIATE WHEN THERE ARE
BABIES IN CAGES.
DOES THAT MEAN WE WILL BE
VIOLENT, NO.
DINNER WITH HER FAMILY WHEN
SHE'S TAKING OUR TAX DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> IT WASN'T UNTIL WE HAD
3-YEAR-OLDS IN CAGES THAT THESE
PEOPLE COULDN'T GO INTO PUBLIC.
>> OF COURSE IT'S FORCED ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE AISLE AND IS
MUCH WORSE AND MUCH HARDER TO DO
ANYTHING IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: SPARE MEAN.
FOR DECADES, HOLLYWOOD AND THE
LEFT HAVE DRIVEN ANY SEMBLANCE
OF DECENCY AND CIVILITY FROM THE
MOVIE HOUSE AS WELL AS THE
LECTURE HALL.
THEY HAVE CHEAPENED EVERYTHING
FROM MUSIC TO FASHIONS, BUT
TRUMP IS TO BLAME FOR THE
VULGARITY OF THE CULTURE?
NICE TRY.
CONVERSATION, DEBATE, IDEAS.
THE LEFT HAS CREATED A POLITICAL
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     D
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     M
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     N
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     Z
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     T
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     O
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     N
CULTURE WHERE DENOMINATION     F
OPPONENTS AND BOYCOTTS ARE
ROUTINE.
IF YOU CAN'T BEAT THEM IN A
DEBATE, TRY TO SHUT THEM DOWN
ALTOGETHER.
ORGANIZED CHAOS IS THEIR
FAVORITE TOOL.
BUT THE IDEA IS NOT TO COME TO
SOME COMMON UNDERSTANDING OR
EVEN WIN AN ARGUMENT OF COURSE,
BUT TO DESTROY POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
AND YOU BET, AND ATTEMPT TO
SILENCE THEM.
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE URGING
UPRISINGS ONLINE TO DENY
REPUBLICAN WOMEN SAFE HAVENS,
PEAS, JUST HAVING DINNER IN
FAMILY?
THEY WON'T ALLOW THAT, SOMETHING
IS DEEPLY WRONG.
NOW IS THE MOMENT FOR ALL PEOPLE
RIGHT AND LEFT TO CONDEMN THAT
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE AND THOSE
ADVOCATING IT.
THREATENING, YELLOW AND DELICATE
YELLING AND HARANGUING OFFICIALS
AND PUBLIC WON'T CREATE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES OR A BETTER POLICY.
EVEN CHUCK SCHUMER SAID THAT
TODAY, GOOD FOR HIM.
IT WILL ONLY HARDEN THE
POLITICAL DIVIDE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND PERHAPS LEAD TO VIOLENCE.
AND ANY BLOOD SPILLED, WHAT
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED A YEAR
AGO TO STEVE SCULLY'S, ANY BLOOD
NEVER TRUMP FIRST, CONDONING.